Okay, now that we understand how to build
combinational logic gates using CMOS, let's
turn our attention to the timing specifications
for the gates.
Here's a simple circuit consisting of two
CMOS inverters connected in series, which
we'll use to understand how to characterize
the timing of the inverter on the left.
It will be helpful to build an electrical
model of what happens when we change V_IN,
the voltage on the input to the left inverter.
If V_IN makes a transition from a digital
0 to a digital 1, the PFET switch in the pullup
turns off and the NFET switch in pulldown
turns on, connecting the output node of the
left inverter to GROUND.
The electrical model for this node includes
the distributed resistance and capacitance
of the physical wire connecting the output
of the left inverter to the input of the right
inverter.
And there is also capacitance associated with
the gate terminals of the MOSFETs in the right
inverter.
When the output node is connected to GROUND,
the charge on this capacitance will flow towards
the GROUND connection through the resistance
of the wire and the resistance of the conducting
channel of the NFET pulldown switch.
Eventually the voltage on the wire will reach
the potential of the GROUND connection, 0V.
The process is much the same for falling transitions
on V_IN, which cause the output node to charge
up to V_DD.
Now let's look at the voltage waveforms as
a function of time.
The top plot shows both a rising and, later,
a falling transition for V_IN.
We see that the output waveform has the characteristic
exponential shape for the voltage of a capacitor
being discharged or charged though a resistor.
The exponential is characterized by its associated
R-C time constant, where, in this case, the
R is the net resistance of the wire and MOSFET
channel, and the C is the net capacitance
of the wire and MOSFET gate terminals.
Since neither the input nor output transition
is instantaneous, we have some choices to
make about how to measure the inverter's propagation
delay.
Happily, we have just the guidance we need
from our signaling thresholds!
The propagation delay of a combinational logic
gate is defined to be an upper bound on the
delay from valid inputs to valid outputs.
Valid input voltages are defined by the V_IL
and V_IH signaling thresholds, and valid output
voltages are defined by the V_OL and V_OH
signaling thresholds.
We've shown these thresholds on the waveform
plots.
To measure the delay associated with the rising
transition on V_IN, first identify the time
when the input becomes a valid digital 1,
i.e., the time at which V_IN crosses the V_IH
threshold.
Next identify the time when the output becomes
a valid digital 0, i.e., the time at which
V_OUT crosses the V_OL threshold.
The interval between these two time points
is the delay for this particular set of input
and output transitions.
We can go through the same process to measure
the delay associated with a falling input
transition.
First, identify the time at which V_IN cross
the V_IL threshold.
Then find the time at which V_OUT crosses
the V_OH threshold.
The resulting interval is the delay we wanted
to measure.
Since the propagation delay, t_PD, is an upper
bound on the delay associated with *any* input
transition, we'll choose a value for t_PD
that's greater than or equal to the measurements
we just made.
When a manufacturer selects the t_PD specification
for a gate, it must take into account manufacturing
variations, the effects of different environmental
conditions such as temperature and power-supply
voltage, and so on.
It should choose a t_PD that will be an upper
bound on any delay measurements their customers
might make on actual devices.
From the designer's point of view, we can
rely on this upper bound for each component
of a larger digital system and use it to calculate
the system's t_PD without having to repeat
all the manufacturer's measurements.
If our goal is to minimize the propagation
delay of our system, then we'll want to keep
the capacitances and resistances as small
as possible.
There's an interesting tension here: to make
the effective resistance of a MOSFET switch
smaller, we would increase its width.
But that would add additional capacitance
to the switch's gate terminal, slowing down
transitions on the input node that connects
to the gate!
It's a fun optimization problem to figure
out transistor sizing that minimizes the overall
propagation delay.
Although not strictly required by the static
discipline, it will be useful to define another
timing specification, called the "contamination
delay".
It measures how long a gate's previous output
value remains valid after the gate's inputs
start to change and become invalid.
Technically, the contamination delay will
be a lower bound on the delay from an invalid
input to an invalid output.
We'll make the delay measurements much as
we did for the propagation delay.
On a rising input transition, the delay starts
when the input is no longer a valid digital
0, i.e., when V_IN crosses the V_IL threshold.
And the delay ends when the output becomes
invalid, i.e., when V_OUT crosses the V_OH
threshold.
We can make a similar delay measurement for
the falling input transition.
Since the contamination delay, t_CD, is a
lower bound on the delay associated with *any*
input transition, we'll choose a value for
t_CD that's less than or equal to the measurements
we just made.
Do we really need the contamination delay
specification?
Usually not.
And if not's specified, designers should assume
that the t_CD for a combinational device is
0.
In other words a conservative assumption is
that the outputs go invalid as soon as the
inputs go invalid.
By the way, manufacturers often use the term
"minimum propagation delay" to refer to a
device's contamination delay.
That terminology is a bit confusing, but now
you know what it is they're trying to tell
you.
So here's a quick summary of the timing specifications
for combinational logic.
These specifications tell us how the timing
of changes in the output waveform (labeled
B in this example) are related to the timing
of changes in the input waveform (labeled
A).
A combinational device may retain its previous
output value for some interval of time after
an input transition.
The contamination delay of the device is a
guarantee on the minimum size of that interval,
i.e., t_CD is a lower bound on how long the
old output value stays valid.
As stated in Note 2, a conservative assumption
is that the contamination delay of a device
is 0, meaning the device's output may change
immediately after an input transition.
So t_CD gives us information on when B will
start to change.
Similarly, it would be good to know when B
is guaranteed to be done changing after an
input transition.
In other words, how long do we have to wait
for a change in the inputs to reflected in
an updated value on the outputs?
This is what t_PD tells us since it is a upper
bound on the time it takes for B to become
valid and stable after an input transition.
As Note 1 points out, in general there are
no guarantees on the behavior of the output
in the interval after t_CD and before t_PD,
as measured from the input transition.
It would legal for the B output to change
several times in that interval, or even have
a non-digital voltage for any part of the
interval.
As we'll see in the last video of this chapter,
we'll be able to offer more insights into
B's behavior in this interval for a subclass
of combinational devices.
But in general, a designer should make no
assumptions about B's value in the interval
between t_CD and t_PD.
How do we calculate the propagation and contamination
delays of a larger combinational circuit from
the timing specifications of its components?
Our example is a circuit of four NAND gates
where each NAND has a t_PD of 4 ns and t_CD
of 1 ns.
To find the propagation delay for the larger
circuit, we need to find the maximum delay
from an input transition on nodes A, B, or
C to a valid and stable value on the output
Y.
To do this, consider each possible path from
one of the inputs to Y and compute the path
delay by summing the t_PDs of the components
along the path.
Choose the largest such path delay as the
t_PD of the overall circuit.
In our example, the largest delay is a path
that includes three NAND gates, with a cumulative
propagation delay of 12 ns.
In other words, the output Y is guaranteed
be stable and valid within 12 ns of a transition
on A, B, or C.
To find the contamination delay for the larger
circuit, we again investigate all paths from
inputs to outputs, but this time we're looking
for the shortest path from an invalid input
to an invalid output.
So we sum the t_CDs of the components along
each path and choose the smallest such path
delay as the t_CD of the overall circuit.
In our example, the smallest delay is a path
that includes two NAND gates with a cumulative
contamination delay of 2 ns.
In other words, the output Y will retain its
previous value for at least 2 ns after one
of the inputs goes invalid.